is if you needed more proof that higher
education is the most sophisticated and
most predatory racket underway in this
country right now there's this Harvard
just announced its classes will be
entirely online this fall but the school
isn't taking a single dime off its
tuition that's still $50,000 a year of
course it's by design that tuition is
not paying for a better education that's
paying for bloated administrator
salaries and an army of pointless
bureaucrats in fact not just pointless
but some of them poisonous right now for
example the University of California
system has two hundred and eighty
thousand students enrolled at the same
time it has two hundred twenty seven
thousand employees do the math on that
Isaac Morehouse has he's a CEO of crash
Co it's a company that helps people
without degrees get good-paying jobs he
also founded praxis an organization
that's now paying kids a thousand
dollars to drop out of college and enter
apprenticeships instead I think we're
happy to have you on
always so it seems like this is a moment
for you because a lot of people correct
me if I'm wrong are starting to realize
that college is a scam yeah it's a huge
moment I mean this college has basically
been scamming young people for a long
time and it's been able to get away with
it because they're heavily subsidized
through tax dollars protected from
competition they're essentially
monopolies and there's been a religious
superstition that you have to get that
degree you got to get that bullet point
on your resume and I think more and more
people see that that's not true I mean
what you just said if you're paying
fifty thousand dollars to go to classes
on zoom' you know the argument that
you're getting some intangible benefits
like the only intangibles are the the
pensions the administrators are getting
that's what that's funded so more people
are awake to this which i think is a
great thing it's been a huge opportunity
for people to see what really matters on
the job market so it's I mean I mean
this isn't just a conversation about the
ethics of whether or not to go to
college because I think there are big
ethical implications in it but the money
doesn't even make sense give us an idea
because most parents are afraid not to
send their kids to college give us an
idea what
options are if you don't want to send
your kids so what their options are yeah
it's it's amazing how few people think
about what it is they actually need to
win a job and I'll tell you right now
that that you know hey look I bought a
degree and I listed it on my resume you
can burn your resume I'm telling you
that's not how you get a job anymore you
have to gain some real skills and then
pitch companies on the value you can
create for them I mean that's kind of
what we help people do with crash is to
create you know something that showcases
their skills in a tangible way instead
of just saying here this institution
said that I'm okay you know I passed and
so if you can get those skills like I'm
telling you right now you can do this in
months or a year or two a lot of
programs like praxis you don't even pay
tuition unless you get a job so there's
direct accountability and a lot of boot
camps out there you know you can go and
you can apprentice or intern and get the
experience first before you think a
bunch of money that you're never going
to get back I mean a college isn't gonna
give you a refund if you don't get hired
they're gonna be laughing all the way to
the bank with that money so there's a
lot of opportunity out there to discover
you know the kind of things that you're
interested in and then build things
around those actually do something
tangible instead of just you know sort
of following the rules and saying hey I
got this credential so there's not a
correlation between getting some
credential and your effectiveness really
quickly how does a parent or a child
who's thinking about what to do next
get involved with crash yeah so crash is
really designed for if you are on the
job market now and that could be an
internship it could be a first job it's
really a way to find how to showcase
your skills and not have to rely on
having fancy credentials or anything
like that and put together a compelling
pitches to companies and we kind of help
you walk through that process and you
know if you're ready for that if you're
ready for the job market now definitely
check out crash CO if you're not I would
encourage you to look into boot camps if
you're interested in coding there's a
host of coding boot camps praxis is a
boot camp for non coders and again right
now praxis is offering to you if you're
going to drop out of college they'll pay
you $1,000
and it's really rigorous training in the
skills in demand in fast-growing
companies today so I mean
just a couple places to start but
there's there's more opportunity than
there's ever been to learn relevant
skills and I'm telling you none of that
opportunity is in college classrooms
right now so right we're all unlearning
the GI Bill 75 years later Isaac great
to see you tonight thank you so much
thanks for having me Tucker